[Musique]
et
alors
a new york les employés d'amazones
trouver leur chant de la victoire
en avril les salariés de l'entrepôt jf
kate ont voté pour la création d'un
syndicat une première historique aux
états unis depuis qu amazon a été créé
il y à 28 ans avec son look de rappeur
chrismousse est à l'origine du mouvement
non vous savez quand les gens s'unissent
ce sont eux qui ont le pouvoir les
entreprises ont beau avoir l'argent nous
les gens normaux on leur a montré qu'on
pouvait les battre
et une fois encore si on n'obtient pas
ce qu'on veut on fera grève comme en
2020 quand l'employé d'amazon organise
un débrayage dans son entrepôt pour
améliorer les conditions de sécurité
amazon avait aussitôt écraser la
contestation est renvoyée l'employé mais
une fois au chômage chrismousse décide
de prendre sa revanche ils organisent
une campagne pour créer un syndicat est
contre toute attente ils gagnent les
employés ose réclamer de meilleurs
salaires et des conditions de travail
plus sûr je veux qu'on ait des salaires
convenables et pas des salaires
d'esclaves des gens se font licencier
pour être partie de leur poste 2 minutes
trop tôt d'autres parce qu'ils étaient
assis sur une marche de ses activi se
sont réunis pour soutenir la création
d'un syndicat dans un deuxième entrepôt
amazon de new york le vote aura lieu
quelques jours plus tard
les jeunes doivent se mobiliser et
former un nouveau mouvement syndical
voilà la nouvelle école nous n'en sommes
qu'au début vous savez c'est une
révolution
avant le vote les syndicalistes
attendent des employés à l'arrêt de bus
de l'entrepôt ils veulent les mobiliser
pour l'élection
beaucoup de salariés ne se pas s'arrêter
qu'à l'entreprise ces pressions amazon
aurait dépensé plus de 4 millions
d'euros en 2021 pour contrer les
initiatives des travailleurs
il ya une campagne contre ce mouvement
syndical
des consultants sont payés pour entrer
dans l'entreprise semer la discorde
diffuser une propagande contre le
syndicat
et dire aux employés de voter non dans
cette offre d'emploi amazon cherche un
analyse capable de repérer les menaces
d'organisations syndicales et d'un
informé ses supérieurs
dans une vidéo interne destiné à ses
salariés l'entreprise explique sa
position oui nous ne pensons pas que les
syndicats soient dans l'intérêt de nos
clients de nos actionnaires et surtout
de nos collaborateurs france 24 a
contacté amazon pour une interview nous
sommes toujours sans réponse
le succès du mouvement syndical chez
amazon inspirent les salariés d'autres
entreprises emblématiques américaine
démobilisation apparaît chez apple dans
les magasins de sport à ria ou encore
chez starbucks ses employés viennent
d'apprendre la création d'un syndicat
dans leur café de new york
quand ils sont rentrés je les ai
embrassé
moi j'étais très nerveux sur les 3
premiers votes on a eu deux noms j'étais
anxieux je me disais oh mon dieu on va
perdre ans
mais finalement ils ont gagné haut la
main ce café est le 41e de la chaîne a
formé un syndicat edwin a milité pour sa
création je suis vraiment très fier j'ai
l'impression de faire partie d'un
immense mouvement à new york le salaire
de départ chez starbucks est de 14 euros
60 de leurs insuffisant pour vit dans
l'une des villes les plus chères au
monde et do in 23 ans vit toujours chez
son oncle et sa tante malgré ces heures
supplémentaires
je travaille 50 heures par semaine ce
qui est dingue je dois assurer plusieurs
services car sinon les magasins ferment
par manque de personnel
depuis la pandémie de kovy de 19 la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre a rendu le
marché du travail plus favorables au
travail en est essentielle ils peuvent
faire entendre leurs revendications plus
facilement
l'entreprise a certes beaucoup d'argent
et de pouvoir à correcteur des mois je
pense que quand les petits gens se
mobilisent en nombre ce sont eux qui
détiennent ce pouvoir sans nous
starbucks n'existe pas nous sommes
starbucks
les employés de 200 autres restaurants
starbucks devraient voter prochainement
pour la création d'un syndicat alors
assistons à une révolution aux états
unis ruth milk man est professeur de
sociologie elle analyse les mouvements
ouvriers en déclin dans le pays ces
dernières années
la victoire chez amazon la prise par
surprise
j'étais stupéfaite de voir ça on assiste
certainement une renaissance du
syndicalisme mais de là à ce que la
tendance qui était au déclin des
syndicats s'inverse c'est trop tôt pour
le dire les jeunes travailleurs s'y
intéressent beaucoup et j'aime le dire
maintenant les syndicats sont de nouveau
cool
selon un sondage de l'institut gallup
68% des américains soutiennent les
syndicats un record depuis 1965 même à
vent de renouveau souffle aussi sur les
syndicats historique
[Applaudissements]
sorti tout budget est une organisation
qui réunit femme de ménage voiturier et
concierges sur la très chic paca venu à
manhattan des milliers d'employés se
mobilisent pour garder leurs avantages
acquis pendant la pandémie comme la
prise en charge de leur assurance santé
et la hausse du nombre de congés payés
leurs employeurs veulent supprimer leurs
nouveaux droits acquis les salariés
menacent de faire grève
3000 immeuble new yorkais seraient
impactés pendant la crise du coc vide on
était considérés comme des travailleurs
est essentielle et maintenant on veut
être traité comme tel on veut un salaire
juste et garder nos avantages on veut
seulement des conditions normales c'est
tout aux états unis il essaie de se
débarrasser des syndicats parce qu'ils
ne veulent pas respecter les règles du
jeu les leaders syndicaux de faillite au
budget sont optimistes pour l'avenir
nous sommes au début d'une nouvelle ère
dans le pays une ère où les travailleurs
ont le pouvoir et nous les employeurs
ont conscience de ce pouvoir
finalement le syndicat a pu trouver un
accord avec les propriétaires
d'immeubles pour éviter une grève mais
chez amazon la bataille est encore loin
d'être gagné les résultats viennent de
tomber pour le deuxième entrepôt où
avait lieu le vote et les employés ont
largement voté contre la création d'un
syndicat certains activistes n'ont pu
retenir leurs larmes
c'est un marathon pas un sprint et on
sait les travailleurs devraient être
heureux car ils ont fait trembler une
entreprise multi milliardaires avec
cette élection l'acsor malgré les
pressions chris moyles je crois qu'un
mouvement syndical est en marche dans
tout le pays plus de 100 votre peau
amazon voteront prochainement pour la
création d'un syndicat
[Musique]